Hey guys, you hear that creak in the door? That's the opening to the cold. Oh wow. It's the cold open, right? Stop trying to explain the cold open every time we do a cold open. Yeah. It's the creak in the door. Are you guys up for a podcast record?
大家好，听到门轴吱呀的响声了吗？那代表着寒意来袭。哦，哇。是“冷开场”对吧？别每次我们做冷开场时你都试图去解释它。对啊。就是门吱呀一声响。你们准备好录播客了吗？
Yeah. We got a great guest today. Whose guest is it? I don't know, but I can't wait to talk to Bruce Hiddleston. It's gonna be amazing! Somebody fire up the music. Welcome to a new Smartless. Did you go late last night, Willie? How's it going? Listener, we're in the second day of what the business tree calls principal photography
对。我们今天来了一位重磅嘉宾。是谁的嘉宾？我不知道，但我已经迫不及待想和布鲁斯·希德勒斯顿聊聊了。这绝对会精彩绝伦！谁去把音乐放起来。欢迎收看新一期的Smartless。你昨晚弄得很晚吗，威利？最近怎么样？听众朋友们，我们正处于影视界所称的正片拍摄的第二天。
on Will's project. and so far so good, that's what I'm thinking. So far so good, man. Who knows? Who knows? So far so good. I love it. Yeah, but you know a lot.
在威尔的的项目里。到目前为止一切顺利，我是这么想的。目前为止一切顺利，老兄。谁知道呢？谁知道呢？目前为止一切顺利。我喜欢。对，但你懂的很多。
Like if something's going to be sideways, you can smell it on the first day. Yes, and no, it feels good. I mean, you know. Do you want me to take a look at the footage or? Do you mind? Yeah, you just sent it. Yeah, happy.
比如如果有什么事情要出岔子，你在第一天就能闻到味儿。是的，也不尽然，感觉挺好的。我的意思是，你懂的。你想让我看一眼素材还是？你介意吗？对，你刚发过去。对，很高兴。
Happy to do a pass. Email it. Yeah, I'll just. Email it and then a minute later, a couple things. Already? Wait, JB, how's your thing going? How are you feeling down there? Great, great.
很高兴能过目。发邮件吧。好，我这就。发邮件，然后过一会儿，就有几个问题了。这么快？等等，JB，你的情况怎么样？你在那边感觉如何？太棒了，太棒了。
Fun, fun, fun. How about that? Oh, that's good. But I'm back home with the kiddies and the mommy and I saw Franny's doing a musical, her last show at her school as a senior. When is it? Tonight is the final night.
好玩，好玩，好玩。怎么样？哦，那挺好。不过我回到家里陪孩子们和老婆了，我看到弗兰妮正在排演音乐剧，这是她在学校作为高年级学生的最后一场演出。是什么时候？今晚是最后一场。
They're doing Mean Girls that Tina Fey did with her husband. The book and music. With Jeff, yeah, yeah, yeah. I would have loved to have gotten to see husband. The book and music. With Jeff, yeah, yeah, yeah. I would have loved to have gone to see that. Really good. Oh wow. What a great show. I wish I would have seen it on Broadway too.
他们演的是蒂娜·菲和她丈夫合作的《贱女孩》。剧本和音乐。还有杰夫，对，对，对。我本来很想去看她丈夫。剧本和音乐。还有杰夫，对，对，对。我本来很想去看那场演出。真的很棒。哦，哇。多棒的演出啊。我也真希望能在百老汇看到它。
Does she have a big part? She does, yeah. That's great. I'm very proud of her. Will I see you tomorrow, Jason? Yes, you know. Okay, great, great. Well wait.
她有很大的戏份吗？有的，对。那太棒了。我为她感到非常骄傲。我明天能见到你吗，Jason？会的，你知道的。好的，太好了，太好了。等等。
Yes, you know. Are you going or are you? Oh, you're going to the little gathering, a little party thing. Yeah, what are you gonna do? You gonna? I'm gonna skip that and I'm gonna go to our friend's house. Oh, you're gonna go to that gathering, JB?
会的，你知道的。你要去还是？哦，你要去那个小聚会，一个小派对什么的。对，你打算怎么办？你会去吗？我打算跳过那个，我要去我们朋友家。哦，你要去那个聚会吗，JB？
Yeah. Yeah. Now, Willie, what are you gonna do for the big, listener, we're talking about Hollywood's self-congratulatory evening of the Oscars. Right, right, right, right. We're taping this on the eve of the Oscars, right? Yeah. So Willie, you gonna watch with some friends at all,
对。对。那么，威利，对于这个盛大的，听众朋友们，我们正在谈论好莱坞自我标榜的奥斯卡之夜。对，对，对，对。我们在奥斯卡前夕录制这期节目，对吧？对。所以威利，你会和一些朋友一起看，
or are you gonna study your lines and go to bed early? I think that if I had been there, I would have gone with you guys to that. I wouldn't have skipped, I would have come with you, I probably would have come in the car with you and Amanda like we've done before. Yeah. And Sean and Scotty,
还是背背台词早点上床睡觉？我想如果我在那儿的话，我就会跟你们一起去了。我不会缺席，我会跟你们一起来，我可能会像以前那样和妳还有阿曼达坐同一辆车。对。还有肖恩和斯科蒂，
but I guess Sean is too big for that now or something. Yeah, he's huge. Well, he wanted Tony and then he's like, I don't have time for it. I need a follow van. Yeah, yeah. I need a house. No, you guys, I drove you guys last year.
但我想肖恩现在名气太大了，不适合去那种场合了吧。对，他现在红得发紫。嗯，他本来想要托尼奖，然后他就说，我没时间搞这个。我需要一辆保姆车。对，对。我需要一栋房子。不，伙计们，我去年还开车送你们呢。
Who's gonna carry my shoes? Oh, you did, you did. No, we remember we met at my, last year we met at my house and I came down because I was still doing, putting on my tux or whatever it was. And I just hear Jason rummaging through my pantry looking for stuff to eat. And also rummaging through my nose,
谁来帮我拿鞋子？哦，你拿过，你拿过。不，我们记得去年我们在我家集合，我下楼的时候还在穿我的燕尾服还是别的什么。然后我听到杰森在我的食品储藏室里翻找吃的。还在我的鼻子里翻找，
he pulled my nose hairs out. Yeah, well, you know, there was a lot of cameras on these nights, you know, it's not a radio thing. I know, thank God. He really did. You know what, it's funny a radio thing. I know, thank God. You really did. You know what, it's funny that we're talking about this big night because our guest today, and this is one honestly.
他把我的鼻毛都拔出来了。对，好吧，你知道的，这些晚上有很多摄像机拍着，你知道的，这不是广播节目。我知道，谢天谢地。他真的干了。你知道吗，这很有趣，这是广播节目。我知道，谢天谢地。他真的干了。你知道吗，我们谈论这个盛大之夜很有趣，因为我们今天的嘉宾，说实话这就是其中一位。
Let's just get to it, Will, what do you got, a lunch? Well, no, but normally we, normally, normally you're like, oh, what's the segue? And this couldn't be more perfect, like the moment you mentioned it, because, well, first of all, he's been nominated for two Academy Awards. Oh my God.
我们开门见山吧，威尔，你有什么事，要吃午饭吗？哦，没有，不过通常我们，通常，通常你会说，哦，转场是什么？这再完美不过了，就像你提到它的那一刻，因为，首先，他曾获得过两次奥斯卡金像奖提名。哦，我的天哪。
And yeah, yeah, I mean, he's been nominated for, I don't know, 12 Emmys, he's won six. Oh, this isn't some garbage guest. No, no, no, buckle up, you guys. This is, every once in a while, we class it up over here. Yeah. And this, to me, is like gold standard, class it up, actor's actor, I mean, this is one of those guys that I, class it up, actor's actor.
而且，对，对，我的意思是，他获得了，我不知道，12次艾美奖提名，赢得了6次。哦，这不是什么垃圾嘉宾。不，不，不，系好安全带，伙计们。这是，我们这里偶尔也会提高一下格调。对。而这个，对我来说就是黄金标准，提高格调，演员中的演员，我的意思是，这是那种我提高格调，演员中的演员。
I mean, this is one of those guys that I've every performance of his I adore. I love watching him and we all have over the years. He won a Tony in his Broadway debut, Sean, so take that. Yeah, so he's got you licked. And then he's gone on to have so many more awards and nominations that it's countless. I think he's got like two or three Golden Globes.
我的意思是，这是那种他的每一个表演我都爱不释手的人。我喜欢看他的表演，这些年来我们所有人都这样。他在百老汇首秀时就赢得了托尼奖，肖恩，受着吧。对，所以他把你比下去了。而且他随后获得的奖项和提名数不胜数。我想他大概有两三座金球奖。
He's got all sorts of, I mean, it's just incredible. And we know him from, he won a Tony for The Changing Room. He was nominated for the world according to Garp. We loved him on Third Rock for the No Son. I loved him in Mr. Churchill. Oh, this is John Lithgow. It's John Lithgow. Oh, woo!
他有各种各样的奖项，我的意思是，简直难以置信。我们知道他，他因《换衣间》赢得托尼奖。他因《加普的世界》获得提名。我们喜欢他在《歪小子斯科特》中的表现。我喜欢他在《邱吉尔先生》中的演出。哦，这是约翰·利思戈。是约翰·利思戈。哦，哇！
Gentlemen, gentlemen. This is so exciting. Gold standard. Wait, and John, you just got cast in Harry Potter, your Dumbledore. There's all sorts of news, gentlemen. So much stuff to talk about. This is so exciting.
各位，各位。这太令人兴奋了。黄金标准。等等，约翰，你刚刚在《哈利·波特》里获得了一个角色，你演邓布利多。有各种各样的消息，各位。有那么多事情要谈。这太令人兴奋了。
And we were just talking about you yesterday. This is so bizarre. Oh, God. Sean, Sean, Sean, I'm gonna, John, first of all, welcome to Smartless. What an honor to have you on the show today. Yes, that honor is completely mine, you guys. It's a fantastic podcast.
我们昨天还在谈论你。这太离奇了。哦，天哪。肖恩，肖恩，肖恩，我，约翰，首先，欢迎来到Smartless。很荣幸今天能请到你上节目。是的，这份荣幸完全是我的，伙计们。这是一个非常棒的播客。
Truly, truly, truly. And I was excited, and we're all excited, but I know Sean's been excited, because, John, you were quite literally raised in the theater. Yeah. Is that true? Well, yes, it's true.
真的，真的，真的。我很兴奋，我们都很兴奋，但我知道肖恩一直很兴奋，因为，约翰，你简直就是在剧院里长大的。是的。是真的吗？嗯，是的，是真的。
I was a theater rat from, actually the first acting I ever did, I was about two years old, one of Nora's children in a doll's house with my father playing Torvald. Wow. And I remember absolutely nothing about it, but I'm told I was very good. That was the beginning of things. But I was, you know. You set the bar high at two.
我从小就在剧院里厮混，实际上我演的第一场戏，我大约两岁，在《玩偶之家》里饰演娜拉的一个孩子，我父亲扮演托尔瓦德。哇。我对它完全没有记忆，但据说我演得很好。那是事情的开端。但我，你知道的。你两岁时就把标准定得很高。
Yeah. But there were no supporting actor nods back at that age. Did you get a chance to see Doll's House part two? Yes, of course, with Laurie Metcalf. How great was that show? Fantastic, yeah. I love that show. I love Laurie Metcalf.
对。但在那个年龄可没有什么最佳男配角的提名。你有机会看《玩偶之家续集》吗？是的，当然看过，有劳瑞·梅特卡夫参演。那部剧有多棒？棒极了，对。我喜欢那部剧。我喜欢劳瑞·梅特卡夫。
So then was there any other thing that ever got into your head that you might be doing with your life or was it just like, that was it? From a very young age, I thought I should be an artist. I wanted to be an artist. I sort of had a facility and parents that encouraged that and bought me wonderful art supplies and I had great public school art teachers
那么，有没有什么其他的事情曾经进入你的脑海，让你觉得你可能会以此为生，还是说，就是这样？从很小的时候起，我就觉得自己应该成为一名艺术家。我想成为一名艺术家。我有点这方面的天赋，父母也鼓励我，给我买了好用的美术用品，我遇到了很棒的公立学校美术老师。
and I was very serious about it. Did it start with drawing? Drawing and painting and printmaking. But meantime, just as a, like, my dad produced summer Shakespeare festivals and that was my summers, was hanging around, watching rehearsals, being in the plays as like a fairy in Midsummer Night's
我对这件事非常认真。是从画画开始的吗？画画、油画和版画。但与此同时，只是作为，比如，我父亲制作夏季莎士比亚戏剧节，那就是我的夏天，我在周围闲逛，观看排练，在戏剧里跑龙套，比如在《仲夏夜之梦》里演一个仙子
Dream or a foot soldier. In fact, by the time I was a teenager, I was playing bits and pieces in Shakespeare, in repertory, like seven plays a summer. A crazy childhood in Ohio. Now you might not be the right person to answer this, but I've always had a fear of even trying Shakespeare because I think that it would be almost impossible
或者演一个步兵。事实上，到我十几岁的时候，我已经在剧团里扮演莎士比亚戏剧中的零星角色了，一个夏天大约要演七部戏。我在俄亥俄州度过了一个疯狂的童年。现在你可能不是回答这个问题最合适的人选，但我一直对尝试莎士比亚戏剧感到恐惧，因为我觉得
for me to learn the lines because it's basically a different language. But since you started so young, was that a hurdle for you? Or do you think, how difficult a thing is that? Not at all. I mean, you're right. I had the great good luck to just hear that language
记住台词对我来说几乎是不可能的，因为这基本上是另一门语言。但既然你这么早就开始了，这对你来说是一个障碍吗？或者你认为，这是一件多么困难的事情？完全没有。我是说，你是对的。我有极好的运气，一直都能听到那种语言，
all the time, but it is learning another language. Or at least feeling that it is a natural way of communicating. Yeah. Right, you certainly can't paraphrase. No, you have to be precise. You're not throwing a lot of like, I mean, and um. Right. You know.
但它确实就像学习另一门语言。或者至少觉得这是一种自然的交流方式。是的。没错，你当然不能用自己的话去复述。不，你必须精确。你不能加入太多诸如“那个”和“嗯”之类的词。没错。你知道的。
Like, yeah. Although, you know, there's wonderful Shakespeare that completely breaks all the rules. There was a wonderful production of Much Ado About Nothing in New York in my 1970s theater days with Sam Waterston and Kathleen Widows. And it was set in Teddy Roosevelt's America. Kind of ragtime music.
比如，是的。尽管，你知道的，也有完全打破所有规则的精彩莎士比亚戏剧。在我70年代的戏剧生涯中，纽约曾上演过一部精彩的《无事生非》，由山姆·沃特斯顿和凯瑟琳·维多斯主演。背景设定在西奥多·罗斯福的美国。有点像拉格泰姆音乐。
Contemporize the dialogue a bit. Yeah, coming back from World War I. And it was as spirited, it captured the spirit of Shakespeare better than most productions. Yeah, I've seen a few of those. Yeah, sometimes you see those, I remember seeing a, what was it, that Guildhall, I thought in London, it was like, and everybody's on motorcycles and stuff.
把对话做了一些当代化的处理。是的，从第一次世界大战中归来。它充满活力，比大多数制作都更好地捕捉到了莎士比亚的精神。是的，我看过几部这样的。是的，有时你会看到那些，我记得看过一个，是什么来着，伦敦的市政厅，我觉得，每个人都骑着摩托车之类的。
And then, of course, Ray Fiennes, when he did Hamlet on Broadway, was incredible. I really loved that back in the 90s. I thought that was pretty remarkable. But, so John, so you grew up, so your dad was a produced theater and your mom was an actress, is that right? She was a retired actress? She was, but I never really knew her as an actor.
然后，当然，雷·费因斯在百老汇演《哈姆雷特》时简直不可思议。我真的很喜欢90年代的那部作品。我觉得那相当非凡。但是，约翰，所以你长大了，所以你父亲是戏剧制作人，你母亲是个演员，对吗？她是一个退休演员吗？是的，但我从未真正把她当演员看。
She retired early and just sort of kept track of the family. I mean, we literally lived in about eight different places. It was a... Wow. We were like a vaudeville troop, except it was Shakespeare. That's pretty cool. In your blood. And then you go, and then you graduated from high school in New Jersey,
她退休很早，只是负责照顾家庭。我的意思是，我们真的在大概八个不同的地方生活过。那是一个……哇。我们就像一个杂技团，只不过演的是莎士比亚。挺酷的。这是流淌在你的血液里的。然后你去，然后你在新泽西州读完了高中，
I think from in Princeton, New Jersey, right? Your dad was there working. That's right, Princeton High, yeah. Princeton High, and then you went to Harvard. Yeah, nice. And you can, I know, and you continued your, and you were there and you were studying what at Harvard? English, history and literature, very scholarly major,
我想是在新泽西州普林斯顿，对吧？你父亲当时在那里工作。没错，普林斯顿高中，对。普林斯顿高中，然后你去了哈佛。是的，很好。我知道，你继续你的，你在那里在哈佛学什么？英语、历史和文学，非常学术的专业，
but I fell in with the theater gang immediately. And that's when it happened. That's when I decided. You know, I was already like a seasoned actor by pure osmosis. Right. I had just been around actors that I and my siblings I was pretty like a seasoned actor by pure osmosis. I had just been around actors that I and my siblings were like best friends with all these young theater actors,
但我一进去就跟戏剧帮混在一起了。就是那个时候发生的。那是我的决定。你知道的，纯粹通过耳濡目染，我已经是一个经验丰富的演员了。对。我周围都是演员，我和我的兄弟姐妹们纯粹通过耳濡目染，就像是一个经验丰富的演员。我一直和演员们在一起，我和我的兄弟姐妹们跟所有这些年轻的戏剧演员成了好朋友，
mainly sort of graduates from Carnegie Tech who'd come down to do my dad's Shakespeare festivals. I had lived in that world, so it just came very naturally. And I was a campus star at Harvard, and if you're a star at anything at Harvard, you'd better go with the flow, because that is a competitive place. I wasn't good at anything but acting there.
主要是卡耐基理工学院的毕业生，他们来参加我父亲的莎士比亚戏剧节。我生活在那个世界里，所以一切都自然而然地发生了。我是哈佛的校园红人，如果你在哈佛的任何事情上成为红人，你最好顺其自然，因为那是一个竞争激烈的地方。我在那儿除了演戏什么都不擅长。
Yeah, yeah. What about your siblings? Did they go into the same field? No, both my sisters were teachers, and wonderful teachers and they directed student theater. Oh really? And they were, and my older brother was an airline pilot.
对，对。你的兄弟姐妹呢？他们也进入这个行业了吗？没有，我的两个姐姐都是老师，非常优秀的老师，她们还指导学生戏剧。哦，真的吗？而且她们是，我的大哥哥是一名航空公司飞行员。
Wow. Who then retired and worked for the FAA. No way. Wait, did he fly big commercial planes? Yeah, yeah. Oh my God. Charter flights. I was never in an airplane, but he was piloting.
哇。后来退休了，在联邦航空局工作。不会吧。等等，他开的是大型商业飞机吗？对，对。哦，我的天哪。包机航班。我从来没坐过飞机，但他是在开飞机。
No, on purpose? Maybe that was against the rules, I don't know. That would unsettle me. I like that whole sense that I never really see the pilot. You do love that. Yeah, because I just don't feel like it's something humans should even be able to do. It's so specialized and...
不，他是故意的吗？也许这违反了规定，我不知道。那会让我感到不安。我喜欢那种从来看不到飞行员的感觉。你确实很喜欢。对，因为我只是觉得这不是人类应该能够做到的事情。这太专业了……
To fly a plane? Yeah, it's just like, how do you do that? You know, if they become human to me, then all the ployables go along with it. But wait, but as you board it, you passed, you just not look into the cockpit? Yeah, I just look right. I look right.
开飞机？对，这就像，你怎么做到的？你知道，如果他们对我来说变得像普通人一样，那所有相关的风险也就随之而来了。但是等等，当你登机时，你走过去，你真的不看一眼驾驶舱吗？对，我就看右边。我只看右边。
You know, Jason, John, you have to understand something about Jason, he has very interesting ways of compartmentalizing things and putting things in certain. It's always, right Sean? It's always fascinating. It's amazing to me. And you're such an, Jason, you're such an easy flyer too, as these guys know, I get quite nervous.
你知道，杰森，约翰，关于杰森，你必须明白一点，他有一种非常有趣的方式来把事情分门别类，把事情放在特定的……一直都是这样，对吧，肖恩？总是那么迷人。这对我来说太神奇了。而且你也是个，杰森，你坐飞机也很轻松，就像这些家伙知道的那样，我其实挺紧张的。
And Jason, just like, you never get fazed. You're like, you give into the, right? Once you're on there. I do, I hit fuck it real quick. Well, my mom was a stewardess or flight attendant for Pan Am for 30 some years. So I would always get nervous when she'd leave, but she always came home.
而杰森，就像，你从来不会慌乱。你就像，你接受了这一切，对吧？一旦你上了飞机。是的，我很快就会开启“去他的”模式。好吧，我妈妈曾是泛美航空公司的空姐或乘务员，干了三十多年。所以我每次她离开时都会紧张，但她总是能回家。
And I'm like, well, you know. I would always make sure I flew the first flight out in the morning so I didn't sleep. So when I got on the plane I was so exhausted I didn't care what happened. Oh, oh, oh. I thought you were flying the first one out because you thought that one had the best odds of landing.
我就想，好吧，你知道的。我总是确保自己赶早上的第一班飞机，这样我就不会睡觉。所以当我上飞机时，我已经精疲力竭了，根本不在乎会发生什么。哦，哦，哦。我还以为你坐第一班飞机是因为你觉得那一班着陆的概率最高呢。
Well that's true. First flight. Yeah. My favorite airline pilot story, beyond my brother's many, many stories, when I was in World According to Garp playing Roberta Muldoon. I wasn't very good.
嗯，这倒也是。第一班航班。对。我最喜欢的航空公司飞行员的故事，除了我哥哥的许多许多故事之外，当我在《加普的世界》里扮演罗伯塔·穆尔杜恩时。我演得不是很好。
I wasn't catching for applause, gentlemen. You're going to get it. No, but there's a lot of audience here. I love it, that Garp! It's amazing! Well, at a certain point early in the flight, the flight attendant came back, this woman in a Delta pilot's uniform, and she crouched next to me
我不是在等掌声，伙计们。你们会给的。不，但这里有很多观众。我太喜欢了，那个《加普》！太棒了！嗯，在飞行早期的某个时刻，空乘人员走回来了，一个穿着达美航空飞行员制服的女性，她在我的旁边蹲下来，
and said how much she appreciated me as Roberta Muldoon and said, Roberta and I have a lot in common. Ah, wow. And it was one of many amazing transactions with trans people way back, this was 40 years ago. Yeah, no, I want to hear. John, John, John, do you remember, hang on, just while we 40 years ago. Yeah, no, I don't want to. John, John, John, do you remember, hang on, just while we're on the flight thing, John,
说她有多么欣赏我饰演的罗伯塔·穆尔杜恩，并说罗伯塔和她有很多共同点。啊，哇。那是与跨性别者进行的许多奇妙交往中的一次，这发生在很久以前，那是40年前。对，不，我想听听。约翰，约翰，约翰，你还记得，等等，就在我们40年前。对，不，我不想。约翰，约翰，约翰，你还记得，等等，在我们谈论飞行的时候，约翰，
do you remember we met on a flight? Uh-oh. And you probably don't remember it, and I think that I dropped my, or you dropped your license and I found your license and I handed it to you, do you remember that? Yes, of course I remember that. Years ago.
你还记得我们在航班上遇见过吗？哦，不。你可能不记得了，我想我掉了，或者你掉了驾照，我找到了你的驾照并把它递给了你，你还记得吗？是的，当然记得。那是多年前的事了。
Yeah. I would have kept that. In fact, I always regretted that I hadn't recalled that when we actually worked together, because we did work together. We sort of did and didn't when we did live in front of a studio audience. When we did, exactly right.
对。我当时应该把它藏起来。事实上，我一直很后悔，当我们真正合作的时候，我居然没有记起这件事，因为我们确实合作过。我们确实合作过，当我们在演播室现场观众面前演出时，算是吧。当我们演的时候，完全没错。
Oh, which one were you on? I was on the same evening as Will and Jason, although they were in the Facts of Life and I was in different strokes. So we didn't really interact except at the parties. I did it all in the family and it was really fun. Wasn't that fun? Wasn't it great?
哦，你演的是哪一个？我和威尔、杰森在同一天演出，尽管他们演的是《细思极恐》（译者注：原文为Facts of Life，指《妙龄女子》），而我演的是《不同 Strokes》（译者注：指《小鬼当家》或《Diff'rent Strokes》）。所以我们除了在派对上，并没有什么真正的互动。我在《一家人》里演过，真的很有趣。难道不有趣吗？不是很棒吗？
Yeah. It was really cool. It was so fun. Now if I'd found John Lithgow's driver's license, I would have kept that. Yeah. That would have just been a great little thing, just keeping my wallet.
对。真的很酷。太有趣了。如果我找到了约翰·利思戈的驾照，我一定会把它留作纪念。对。那会是一件很棒的小事，就当是留着我的钱包。
Well he was across the aisle so I couldn't really, you know, I would have felt been a great little thing, just keeping my wallet. Well, he was across the aisle, so I couldn't really, you know, I would have felt bad. So, so. No, but that was the first time we met. And Sean, you and I used to be neighbors on the lot at Radford when you were in the race. That's right, Third Rock. Yeah, Third Rock.
嗯，他坐在过道对面，所以我真的不能，你知道的，我会觉得这是一件很棒的小事，就留着我的钱包。嗯，他坐在过道对面，所以我真的不能，你知道的，我会觉得不好意思。所以，所以。不，但那是我们第一次见面。肖恩，你和我以前在拉德福德的外景地当过邻居，当时你在拍那个剧。没错，《歪星撞地球》。对，《歪星撞地球》。
Back in the day, that was so many great shows being shot there at that time. All in one lot, yeah. It was kind of amazing. All yelling distance from each other. Did you like doing, John, you had such a facility, obviously because of your intense theater background and your upbringing in the theater.
回想当年，那时候在那里拍摄的优秀剧集太多了。都在同一个外景地，对。简直太神奇了。彼此都在大喊就能听到的距离内。约翰，你喜欢那种表演吗，你有着如此出色的才华，显然是因为你深厚的戏剧背景和在剧院里的成长经历。
Did you like, and Sean, I'll go to you, and also Jason, because all three of you guys have such storied sitcom careers. All of us. What did you, and I did too, but I, what did you, did you like that experience of making a multi-camera show? I absolutely loved it.
你喜欢，肖恩，我要问你，还有杰森，因为你们三个人都有着非常辉煌的情景喜剧生涯。我们所有人。你觉得，我也演过，但我，你觉得，你喜欢制作多机位节目的那段经历吗？我绝对喜欢。
Just, I consider those, it was like the six happiest years as an actor. Just interacting with this great writing staff, the third rock staff was so terrific and it was so inane. Just spending all your time figuring out the funny and entertaining a studio audience on just like three days rehearsal. I just, yeah.
我把那些时光看作是一个演员最快乐的六年。只需与这个伟大的编剧团队互动，《歪星撞地球》的团队太棒了，而且内容如此荒诞。把所有时间都花在琢磨笑点上，并且仅靠三天排练就在现场观众面前表演。我真的，是的。
And you get a fresh script the next week. Yeah, and Third Rock of course was just flat out nutball farce. Yeah, yeah, yeah, it was great. I never thought I would do that. In fact, something happened and I forgot it ever happened. I was asked to be Frasier on Cheers. Oh, wow.
而且下周就能拿到全新的剧本。对，《歪星撞地球》当然是一场彻头彻尾的疯癫闹剧。对，对，对，太棒了。我从没想过我会做那种事。事实上，发生了一件事，我都忘了它曾经发生过。我曾被邀请在《欢乐酒店》中扮演弗雷泽。哦，哇。
Oh my God, I didn't know that. And I turned it down out of hand. I honestly didn't even remember it had happened until Jimmy Burroughs reminded me years and years later when he directed Third Rock. Just because at that point, you know, I had a few movies under my belt. I had a couple of Oscar nominations. Yeah, sure. It was so beneath my dignity. I was such an asshole, a pretentious asshole. But you know, I worked on Saturday Night Live,
哦，天哪，我不知道这件事。我当场就拒绝了。老实说，直到多年后吉米·伯罗斯在导演《歪星撞地球》时提醒我，我才记起这件事曾经发生过。仅仅因为在那个时候，你知道的，我已经拍了几部电影了。我有过几次奥斯卡提名。是的，当然。这太有失我的身份了。我当时真是个混蛋，一个自命不凡的混蛋。但你知道的，我在《周六夜我在《周六夜现场》工作过，
I hosted Saturday Night Live three times in the 80s, and two of those times, Bonnie and Terry Turner were on the writing staff. They pitched it to me, and when they pitched it to me, suddenly it seemed like so much fun. And they, I was the only person they could even imagine playing Dick Solomon because it had to be an alien who was completely clueless but could try anything.
我在80年代主持过三次《周六夜现场》，其中有两次，邦妮和特里·特纳是编剧团队的成员。他们向我推销了这个创意，当他们向我推销时，突然间这一切看起来变得非常有趣。而且他们，我是他们唯一能想象到能扮演迪克·所罗门的人，因为必须是一个对地球一无所知但愿意尝试任何事情的外星人。
Yeah, yeah, that's so great. And what a catch, Joseph Gordon-Levitt. And it was a wonderful. And Justin Johnston. Jane Curtin. And Jane Curtin. Yeah, and the long process of casting it was so exciting. Was it?
对，对，太棒了。约瑟夫·高登-莱维特真是个绝佳的人选。还有简·柯廷。简·柯廷。对，还有漫长的选角过程，太令人兴奋了。是吗？
Did it take a long time? A long time, because in each case, we had to figure out just what is this comic idea? Right. You know, a general who has to inhabit the body of a woman became Kristen Johnston. Yeah. Well, think about that.
花了很长时间吗？很长时间，因为在每一种情况下，我们都必须弄清楚这个喜剧创意到底是什么？对。你知道的，一个必须寄居在一个女人体内的将军，最后变成了克里斯汀·约翰斯顿。对。想想看。一个身材矮小的老头。如果你去推销这个创意，约翰，如果你去推销那个创意，这概念可真是太高大上了。你会想，这节目讲的是什么？好吧，就是这样。对。外星人。
A little old man. If you went to pitch it, John, well if you went to pitch that idea, it's pretty high concept. You're like, what's the show? Okay, so here it is. Yeah. Aliens.
电视台会觉得，等等，什么？好吧，他们已经，这已经确定要拍了。他们来找我推销这个创意，这正是特里·特纳所说的。他说，嗯，这是关于这个外星人家庭的。当然，我有点被骗去开会了。我以为我只是和我的朋友邦妮和特里开个会，但卡西和沃纳以及他们所有人都在那里。
And the network would be like, wait a second, what? Well, they had already, it was already a go. They came to me to pitch it, and that's exactly what Terry Turner said. He said, well, it's about this family of aliens. And of course, I had been sort of tricked into the meeting. I thought I was just having a meeting with my friends, Bonnie and Terry, but Carsey and Werner and they were all there.
我想，天哪，我该怎么以最快的速度拒绝这个？但在五分钟内，他就把我给说服了。突然之间，这看起来就像是，我到底在等什么呢？你当时知道它会播那么久吗，还是你觉得这可能只是一集试播集就结束了，或者最多半个季度？好吧，这是一个离奇的情况，
And I thought, my God, how do I say no to this fast enough? But in five minutes, he had brought me around. It just seemed suddenly like, what in the world have I been waiting for? Did you have any idea that it might go as long as it did, or did you think it was kind of going to be a pilot and out, or maybe half a season? Well, it was a freaky situation,
因为当我们最终制作这部剧时，我们已经拍了试播集，它确实被NBC看中了，但它是作为季中替补被接纳的，所以在任何人看到它之前，我们已经拍了13集了。到了这个时候，我们已经意识到，哦，天哪，我们手里真的有好东西。我们觉得自己口袋里揣着希望之星钻石。
because when we finally produced the show, we had done the pilot, and it was picked up all right by NBC, but it was picked up as a mid-season replacement, so we had done 13 of them before anybody had seen it. Well into this, we had realized, oh my God, we really have something here. We felt like we had the Hope Diamond in our pocket.
我的意思是，你知道当你对某件你自信是伟大的事情付出足够多的努力时，你会变得多么自负。你处在自己的泡沫里。但我们能够把所有精彩的剧集放在最前面。我们有那13集来琢磨笑点，来弄清楚这部剧到底是什么。
I mean, you know how cocky you can get when you have been working hard enough on something you persuade yourself is great. You're in your bubble. But we were able to sort of frontline all the great episodes. We had had those 13 episodes to figure out the funny, to figure out what this show was.
你知道的，在很多情况下，你回过头去看一部伟大剧集的最初试播集，比如《宋飞传》，你会发现他们当时还没找到感觉。对，没错。我们有13次机会去寻找感觉，它在1季中1月份首播，然后啪的一下，就这么火了。你知道的，这里面有一种自由，
You know, in so many cases, you go back and see the original pilot episode of a great show like Seinfeld, and you realize they hadn't found it yet. Yeah, right. We had 13 chances to find it, and it was released mid-season in January, and bam, just hit like that. You know, there's a sort of a freedom in that,
从某种意义上说，是的，你会觉得自己手里有好东西，但由于它还没有接受市场的检验，所以没有自我膨胀，对吧？所以这里面有一种纯粹性。我记得在较小的规模上，但当杰森，当我们制作《发展受阻》时，在它播出之前我们拍了那么多。我记得在那段时间里，在那个泡沫里
in the sense that, yes, you can feel that you have something, but there is an absence of ego because it hasn't been received yet, right? So there's a purity to that. And I remember on a smaller scale, but when Jason, when we did rest development, we shot so many before it aired. And I remember in that time, in that bubble
从大约7月到11月的那一年里，我们只是在制作这个东西，没有人看着我们。这种无人观看的状态带来了一种自由。你不需要去保护任何东西。对，你不需要保护。你没有什么可失去的。
from sort of that year, from July till November, we were just making this thing and there was nobody watching us. And there was a freedom in that of nobody watching. You don't have to protect anything. Yeah, you don't have to protect. You don't have anything to lose.
好吧，这是一场走钢丝的表演。你可以冒险，而且你不用担心，因为没有人看着。你知道我的意思吗？它只是给了你一个寻找它的机会。而且你们还有额外的挑战。我们至少有现场观众。当他们笑的时候，我们就知道我们很搞笑。
Well, it's a high wire out. You can take chances and you're not worried because there's nobody watching. Do you know what I mean? It just gives you a chance to find it. And you had the added challenge. We at least had a studio audience. And when they laughed, we knew we were funny.
对。所以从某种意义上说，在人们真正看到它之前，你们都是在盲目飞行。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。所以这是一个有趣的，所以你离开哈佛，然后去，我记得是拿了富布赖特奖学金什么的去了兰达戏剧学院，对吧？
Right. So in a sense, you were flying blind until people actually saw it. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. So here's an interesting, so you leave Harvard and then you go on a, I think like a Fulbright scholarship or something to Lambda, is that right?
没错，是的。在兰达呆了两年。我的意思是，所以你去过，我一直惊叹于，你知道的，我们有足够多来自英国的真正了不起的人才来到这里工作，他们都受过非常好的训练，备受尊敬，而要反方向去发展是一件困难的事情，
That's right, yeah. Two years from Lambda. I mean, so you go, and I've always marveled that, you know, we have plenty of really amazing talent that comes out of the UK that comes and works over here, and they've all been really well trained, and they're very respected, and it's a difficult thing to go the other direction,
我认为，这里面有一点，对吧？我认为这更难，事实就是如此，或者至少人们是这么认为的。而我认为这是，你知道的，这确实证明了你作为演员和艺术家的能力，我讨厌打破你的幻想，你曾说过你不会成为一名艺术家。你想成为，你就是一名艺术家。
I think, that there's a little bit, right? I think it's a harder, it just is, or at least the perception is that it is. And I thought that it was, you know, it's a real testament to your ability as an actor and as an, I hate to break it to you, you said you're not gonna be an artist. You want to, you are an artist.
你去了那里，真的，你知道的，直接融入其中，作为一个海外的表演者。你在那边也做了很多戏剧表演。你作为一个美国人在英国演过莎士比亚。对，那一定很疯狂。嗯，就像我说的，我确实通过我好奇的成长经历占了先机。
And you went over there and really, you know, just sort of jumped right into that and being a performer over there overseas. And you did a lot of theater over there as well. You did Shakespeare in England as an American. Yeah, that's gotta be wild. Well, as I say, I did have this head start with my curious upbringing.
确实有更多的人流向我们这边，而不是反过来。但我认为这是因为莎士比亚确实是英国演艺学派的脊梁，而我演过很多莎士比亚戏剧。很多美国演员并非如此。没错。但在反方向上，
And it's true that a lot more people flow in our direction than the other way around. But I think it's because Shakespeare really is the spine of the English school of acting, and I had done a lot of Shakespeare. And that's not true of many American actors. Right. But in the other direction,
有大量的美国文化。我的意思是，你会看到澳大利亚演员和英国演员，你简直不敢相信他们的语言有多地道。他们现在甚至不需要方言教练了。他们一辈子都在看《老友节》。但与此同时，但随后你去做了，我想谈谈这一点，那就是，你有那么多精彩的表演，
there's plenty of American culture. I mean, you get Australian actors and English actors who you can't believe how authentic their language is. They don't even need a dialect coach by now. They've been watching friends all their lives. But at the same time, but then you go and you do, and I wanted to get to this, which was, you've so many amazing performances
这些年来我都非常喜欢和崇拜，就像其他人一样，但你去《王冠》中扮演了一个标志性的角色，你扮演了温斯顿·丘吉尔，在我看来，恕我对其他所有扮演过温斯顿·丘吉尔的人无意，对我而言，这就是最经典的温斯顿·丘吉尔。我当时深深地被它吸引住了。
that I've just really enjoyed and adored like everybody else over the years, but you go and you take an iconic character in The Crown, you play Winston Churchill, which I think, for my money, and this is no disrespect to anybody else who's ever played Winston Churchill, to me, it's the defining Winston Churchill. And I was so riveted by it.
对，太不可思议了。杰森，我知道你没看过《王冠》，你一定要为了约翰去看一看。太震撼了，是的，这是一次令人难以置信的表演。对于一个英国标志性人物来说，你再也找不到比温斯顿·丘吉尔更具代表性的人物了。好吧，他们居然让我去演，这简直有点让人大吃一惊，
Right, it's incredible. Jason, I know you haven't watched The Crown, you have to see it just for John. It's mind blowing, yeah, it's an incredible performance. You can't get more iconic for an English character than Winston Churchill. Well, it was kind of astonishing that they even asked me to do it,
但我的意思是，很大程度上是因为他们在那个故事中对丘吉尔的定位。它不是历史剧。它几乎就像一部家庭剧。这是一个极其亲密和个人的视角，展现了丘吉尔的所有古怪、病痛和不安全感。这正是我所借鉴的。古怪、病痛和不安全感。
but I mean, so much of it was the way they situated Churchill in that story. It wasn't a historical drama. It was like almost a family drama. It was an extremely intimate and personal look at Churchill with all of his eccentricities and infirmities and insecurities. And that's very much what I took off from. eccentricities and infirmities and insecurities.
这正是我所借鉴的。不过一定很让人畏惧。确实非常可怕，除了所有的英国演员都热情地欢迎我加入，他们对我的信心比我自己对自己的信心还要足。我只是投入到工作中去。我发现，你知道的，我在所有研究中最有趣的事情，我发现的，
That's very much what I took off from. Must have been daunting though. It was very scary, except that all the English actors welcomed me in, they had more confidence in me than I had in myself. And I just went to work at it. I found, you know, the most interesting thing I did in all my research, what I found,
是阅读所有关于他童年、少年和青年时期的经历，他极其缺乏安全感，在成长过程中是个失败者，父母对他的忽视让他觉得自己是个搞砸一切的人，仿佛有太多人对他的期望让他承受不住，因此他生活中的许多事情纯粹是过度补偿。所以当你步入晚年时，对我来说，
was reading all about him as a child and as a boy and as a young man, tremendously insecure, growing up a failure with very neglectful parents and just feeling like a screw up, like there had been so many expectations of him that he would, so that so many things in his life were pure overcompensation. So you approach your old age and to me,
你童年时的所有特征都会被激活。我大致就是从这一点切入的。我想这就是人们觉得它有点耳目一新的原因吧。这很有趣。是的，他有着那样童年，而他成年后的生活丰富多彩，做过各种各样的事情，对吧？比如海军大臣之类的，对吧？但有着那么多巨大的成功和惨痛的失败。并且像抛物线一样不断地从一次失败中恢复过来。
all the characteristics you had in childhood kick in. I sort of worked from that. And I think that's what people thought was kind of new about it. That is interesting. Yeah, and he had such a childhood and his adult life was varied in the things that he did, right? Sort of head of the Admiralty and all that kind of stuff, right? But so many huge successes and colossal failures. And kind of constantly recovering one from another like a parabola.
我问导演斯蒂芬·戴德利他为什么选我。我已经答应了，我们坐下来吃早餐。他的第一反应是，嗯，丘吉尔的母亲是个美国人。确实如此。她是巴尔的摩的贵族。美国温斯顿·丘吉尔与并非温斯顿·丘吉尔的英国人之间存在着巨大的差异。
I asked Stephen Daldry, the director, why he had cast me. I'd said yes, and we sat down for breakfast. His first response was, well, Churchill's mother was an American. That's true. She was this Baltimore aristocrat. There was as much difference between an American Winston Churchill and Englishmen who are not Winston Churchill.
他是个相当罕见的例外，我想这派上了用场。太有趣了。那么，这和在《浑身是劲》里扮演牧师一样具有挑战性吗？那在它自己的方式下也是一种挑战。仅仅因为。你是不是很遗憾自己没有纵情狂欢？我讨厌那部戏。
He was quite an anomaly, and I think that came in handy. That's so interesting. What about, was it as challenging as playing the Reverend in Footloose? That was a challenge in its own way. Just because. Are you bummed you didn't cut loose? I hated that one.
我觉得，你知道的，实际上，现在回过头去看《浑身是劲》，我觉得那真的是一部好电影。这是一部很棒的电影。我很喜欢这部电影。里面的内容太丰富了。导演赫伯特·罗斯和编剧迪恩·皮奇福德，他们真的很认真地对待这个故事。我觉得我必须更认真地对待肖恩牧师这个角色。
I felt like, you know, it was actually, Footloose, I go back and look at Footloose now and I think that was a really good movie. It's a great movie. I love the movie. There was so much meat on the bone. Herbert Ross, the director, and Dean Pitchford, who wrote it, they really took this story seriously. And I felt I had to take this character, Reverend Shaw, more seriously.
而我，一个几乎没有宗教信仰的人，我居然主动去找了一个传教士。我在黄页里查到一个神的教会的部会，然后打电话去寻求精神上的建议。哇，哇。你会把那个联系方式分享给杰森吗？那太好了。
And I, who have virtually no religion in me, I actually sought out a preacher. I, in the yellow pages, I looked up an assembly of God ministry, and called up and sought spiritual advice. Wow, wow. Would you share that contact with Jason? That'd be great.
他能用得上。但我感到我必须找到一个真正相信自己所作所为的人，如果我要去模仿他的话。好吧，然后我确信你把这一点应用到了《秘密会议》中，你在《秘密会议》里的表现太棒了。简直不可思议。多美的电影啊。那是一份了不起的工作。
He could use. But I felt I had to find someone who truly believed what he was doing if I'm gonna imitate it. Well and then I'm sure you apply that to Conclave, and you were amazing in Conclave. Just incredible. What a beautiful movie. That was a fabulous job.
那是与斯坦利·图齐和伊莎贝拉·罗塞里尼在罗马度过的两个月。太棒了，我喜欢那部电影。我可以想象，你一定被各种剧本、机会或关于在不同事物和流派中扮演角色的讨论所淹没，因为你演过太多不同的东西，不同的流派。
That was two months in Rome with Stanley Tucci and Isabella Rossellini. Amazing, I love that movie. I would imagine that you are flooded with scripts or opportunities or conversations about parts in so many different things and genres because you have done so many different things, different genres.
没有人会说你是一个电视演员、电影演员、舞台演员、喜剧演员、正剧演员，大角色、小角色，你什么都演过，而且在这么长的时间里一直保持着如此高的水平。你是如何做到这一点的，驱动你做出决定的主要因素是什么？好吧，听着，杰森，我们都是演员。你心里很清楚，我们其实并没有像大家想象的那样做出那么多的选择。
No one could say that you are a television actor, a film actor, a stage actor, comedy, drama, big parts, small parts, you've just done everything and it's such a high level for so long. How are you able, what's the main thing that drives you towards your decisions? Well, look, Jason, we're all actors. You know perfectly well, we don't do nearly as much choosing
你只是在等待好的东西、好的人和好的剧作，而这非常罕见。老实说，我觉得你刚刚连珠炮般说出的几乎所有角色，几乎都让人感到尴尬，这太奉承了，但它们都不是我主动寻找甚至事先知晓的。
as everybody thinks we do. You just wait for good things and good people and good writing, and it's very rare. I honestly feel like almost all the roles that you just rattled off, almost embarrassing, it's so complimentary, but none of them are things that I sought out or even knew about.
我只是成了别人灵光一现的产物。就像我记得乔纳森·戴米多年前拍过一部名为《我是谁》的小型电视电影。讲的是一个倒霉的社区剧院演员，每个人都不断找他去演。这些角色对一直我来说都是个惊喜。对，这证明了你的才华，
I was somebody else's brainstorm. And it's like, I remember Jonathan Demme did a little television film years ago called Who Am I This Time? About some hapless community theater actor whom everybody kept coming to to play. The roles have always been a surprise to me. Right, and it's a testament to your talent
你能够以这样一种方式来塑造你对角色的理解，从而能够把它演得非常好。你知道的，这就像是，你会想，好吧，这就是我这个月或今年得到的机遇，所以我最好想办法把它演好，因为这是接踵而至的唯一角色。是的，我的意思是，这是一种过于谦逊的方式。
that you're able to craft your take on the character in such a way where you're able to play it really well. You know, it's like it becomes, you're like, okay, so this is the opportunity I'm being given this month or this year, and so I better figure out a way to play it well, because it's the only part that's coming down the pike. Yeah, I mean, it's sort of an overly humble humble way.
而且我很乐意接受，我想我最出名的就是时刻准备着、乐意并且能够胜任。对，对，对。我的意思是，顺便说一句，这可不是小事。而且这很离奇，我刚刚看了我去年和杰弗瑞·拉什一起拍的一部电影的首映，名叫《珍妮·彭的规则》，我强烈建议你们去搜来看看。它即将小范围上映，
And I'm game, I guess I'm best known for being ready, willing, and able. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I mean, that's no small thing, by the way. And it's very cockeyed, I just saw the premiere of a film I did with Jeffrey Rush last year called The Rule of Jenny Penn, which I urge you to look up. It's about to be released in a very narrow release
因为它是一部非常大胆和疯狂的电影，一部心理悬疑惊悚片，我在其中扮演了我自Lazarus博士以来最离谱的角色。他是恐怖电影里的怪物。真的，他就是那个在新西兰一家高级护理中心折磨杰弗瑞·拉什的疯狂家伙。
because it's a very bold and crazy film, a psychological suspense thriller, in which I play by far the most outrageous character I've played since Dr. Lazardo. And he is the monster in a horror movie. He really is, he's that crazy guy who is out to torment Jeffrey Rush in a senior care facility in New Zealand.
我的意思是，这是一部疯狂的电影，而且太棒了。我读了那个剧本，你知道的，新西兰一位了不起的年轻导演名叫詹姆斯·阿什克罗夫特，他说，我必须让你来演这个角色。我当时吓坏了。天哪。但我提醒自己，往往是你害怕的事情……
I mean, this is a crazy film and it is great. I read that script, you know, this wonderful young director in New Zealand named James Ashcroft, he said, I've got to have you play this part. And I was terrified of doing this. My God. But I reminded myself, it's the things
但你做的是什么？当你阅读它，当他说必须是你，而你看着它，然后说，哦，我不知道，我不知道这是什么。我不知道我能不能做到。我不知道我是否会，也许我会失败。那一刻是什么，是什么东西，
that you're afraid of that. But what is that thing that you do? What is that moment of fear when you were able to turn, when you read it and he says it has to be you, and you look at it and you say, oh, I don't know, I don't know what this is. I don't know if I can do it. I don't know if I'm, maybe I'll fail. What is the moment, what is the thing that,
那个声音在说，跳下悬崖吧？我想这通常来自于与电影制片人的对话或Zoom通话。如果存在信任问题，你就会去做。我以前也曾看走眼过，上帝知道，我们都曾看走眼过。但这个，就像我读了《珍妮·彭》，我想，这太可怕了。
the voice that says, take the jump off the cliff? I think it usually comes from a conversation or a Zoom call with the filmmaker. If there's a matter of trust, you do it. And I've been wrong before, God knows, we've all been wrong before. But this, like I read Jenny Penn, and I thought, this is horrific.
那个叫你跳下悬崖的声音？我想它通常来自于与电影制片人的对话或Zoom通话。如果存在信任问题，你就会去做。上帝知道我以前也曾犯过错，我们都曾犯过错。但这一次，就像我读到《珍妮·佩恩》时，我想，这太可怕了。
Who in the world is gonna wanna see this? And I spoke to this guy, James Ashcroft, for an hour and a half, and he just was so persuasive. I just saw so far beyond my first reaction to the script. It's just a matter of being wide open to trusting somebody and being ready to take a chance, because God knows there are plenty of times when it doesn't work out, but you've gotta be bold.
到底有谁会想看这个？我和这个叫詹姆斯·阿什克罗夫特的家伙聊了一个半小时，他实在是太有说服力了。我看到的远远超出了我对剧本的第一反应。这只关乎是否完全向信任某人敞开心扉，以及是否准备好去冒险，因为天知道有很多时候事情并不如意，但你必须大胆。
Does the criteria change for you now at this stage? Like I notice as I'm getting older, my decision to, in terms of working, this again goes to kind of to everybody. Your mindset changes, the things that are important to you change. Is that true or no? Is there a sort of a guiding light for you?
现在到了这个阶段，你的标准会变吗？就像我注意到随着我年龄增长，我做决定时——在工作方面，这也适用于在座的每个人。你的心态变了，对你重要的事情也变了。是这样吗，还是说不是？对你来说有什么指路明灯吗？
Is it, I wanna do something that challenges me or I wanna do something that's fun or I wanna do something that fits my schedule or does that shift? I mean, you know what I mean? What is the criteria? I just think there's so many factors in every case and it always surprises you one way or another. It's basically, is this going to be good? Is this going to be fun? Are people going to want to see this? And am I working, is it good writing with good people? I always say the only hard acting is bad writing.
是“我想做一件挑战自己的事”，还是“我想做一件有趣的事”，还是“我想找一件符合我日程安排的事”，还是说这个标准会转移？我的意思是，你知道我的意思吗？标准到底是什么？我只是觉得每个案例都有太多因素，结果总是会以这样或那样的方式给你带来惊喜。基本上就是：这会很好吗？这会很有趣吗？人们会想看吗？我是在工作吗？这是由优秀的人写出的好剧本吗？我总是说，唯一困难的表演就是糟糕的剧本。
Or shitty people, having to share 12 hours a day with a bunch of jerks is not fun. And you just try to steer clear of that. Sometimes you can't avoid it. Sometimes you take things for the wrong reasons and you pay for it. How do you factor in? Where does family, friends, location, all that stuff,
或者是糟糕的人，每天得和一群混蛋相处12个小时可一点意思也没有。你得尽量避开这种事。有时你无法避免。有时你因为错误的原因接下了工作，然后为此付出代价。你是怎么把这些因素考虑进去的？家庭、朋友、地点，所有这些东西，
how does that all factor in? Tell us a little bit about your, I don't know anything about your personal life. Tell me all the things you don't wanna say. Yeah. So sweet of you to ask, Jason. That's a huge factor. I've been married 43 years to my wife Mary,
这一切都是怎么被考虑进去的？跟我们讲讲你的……我对外不了解你的个人生活。把你不想说的事都告诉我。好吧，你真贴心，杰森。这是一个巨大的因素。我和我妻子玛丽已经结婚43年了，
who's a UCLA professor of history, economic and business history. We are an unlikely couple. God never meant professors and actors to get married because our lives are so different. She is constantly having to adapt to these crazy right angle turns I keep taking. I mean, just think, being asked to play Dumbledore
她是UCLA的历史系教授，专攻经济史和商业史。我们是一对很不相配的夫妻。上帝从来没打算让教授和演员结婚，因为我们的生活太不相同了。她不得不经常适应我不断做出的那些疯狂的直角转弯。我是说，想想看，受邀去扮演邓布利多，
is contemplating literally years in England. Yeah, I know. And that just disrupts everything. Right. We have two kids, I have a third by my first marriage and I have three grandkids with another on the way. And going to England, how are we going to go back and forth? Their lives are very installed here.
意味着要在英国待上好几年。对，我知道。而这会打乱一切。没错。我们有两个孩子，我还有第三个孩子来自我的第一段婚姻，我有三个孙辈，还有一个即将出生。要去英国，我们该怎么来回奔波？他们的生活在这里已经非常稳定了。
Yeah. Family is hugely important to me and it's quite, we are quite exclusive, you know, we're a kind of quiet little family and we get wrenched all over the place. So for a long time when I was asked to do a play in New York, my first reaction was where are we going to live? Because I was so used to house sits and sublets
对，家庭对我来说极其重要，而且我们相当……我们相当排外，你知道的，我们是一个安静的小家庭，却被到处拉扯。所以很长一段时间里，当有人邀请我在纽约演一出戏时，我的第一反应是我们该住哪儿？因为我太习惯于看房、转租，
and apartment hotels, we finally just splurged and bought a beautiful New York apartment so we find, so it, just so I won't have that reaction. I can think of living a wonderful life in New York when I'm doing a New York play, and I never want to stop doing that. By the way, Sean, I have to ask you,
还有公寓式酒店了，最后我们终于大手笔买下了一间漂亮的纽约公寓，这样我们就不用再有那种反应了。当我在纽约演一出纽约的戏剧时，我可以想象在纽约过上美好的生活，而我永远不想停止这样做。顺便问一下，肖恩，我得问你，
are you going to play Oscar Levant again? Cause I missed it. And at the Barbican and this summer in London. I will see you, I will see you. Oh, good. I will be there. That'd be great. I will be there in the first weeks of Dumbledore.
你还要再演奥斯卡·莱万特吗？因为我错过了。还有在巴比肯艺术中心以及今年夏天在伦敦的演出。我会去看你的，我会去看你的。哦，太好了。我会去的。那太棒了。在我扮演邓布利多的前几周我会去的。
Oh, that's great. And I'm doing a play in the West End. That you will be able to see. I did it at the Royal Court in the fall and it's moving to the West End in April. So it's called Giant, a play about Roald Dahl in which I play here. It was a smash hit at the Little Royal Court Theater.
哦，那太棒了。我正在西区演一出戏。你会看到的。我去年秋天在皇家宫廷剧院演过，四月份要转到西区去。这出戏叫《巨人》，讲的是罗尔德·达尔的故事，我在里面扮演他。它在皇家宫廷小剧院大获成功。
But I will finally be able to see. That'd be great. You will not be disappointed. It's so, it's just so cool. I saw little clips of it and heard so many friends rave about it and I was so upset I had missed it. You know, it's on my list of those things
但我终于能看到了。那太棒了。你不会失望的。它太……它太酷了。我看了它的一些小片段，听很多朋友对它赞不绝口，我错过了它，心里非常难过。你知道，它在我的愿望清单上，让我恨不得，
that I kick myself. Well, that's very nice of you. I appreciate that. Yeah, come see, we'll have dinner or whatever. Oh. He won a Tony for it. Of course. We mentioned it earlier, he won a Tony.
捶胸顿足。好吧，你太好了。我很感激。来吧，来看看，我们一起吃晚饭什么的。哦。他为此赢得了一座托尼奖。当然。我们之前提过了，他赢得了一座托尼奖。
And which gets, Sean, don't be, watching him act embarrassed is so embarrassing. Yeah. Because. He thinks he's good and then he tries to play embarrassment. And then he tries to play, Sean, don't be, watching him act embarrassed is so embarrassing. Because- He thinks he's good and then he tries to play embarrassment. And then he tries to play, it's so terrible. But John, you, I mentioned you won, you won a Tony, your first time,
肖恩，别……看他表现得尴尬真是太尴尬了。因为……他觉得自己演得很好，然后他试图表现出尴尬。然后他试图表现出——肖恩，别……看他表现得尴尬真是太尴尬了。因为——他觉得自己演得很好，然后他试图表现出尴尬。然后他试图表现出——这太糟糕了。但是，约翰，你……我提到过你赢了，你赢了一座托尼奖，这是你的第一次，
your first outing on Broadway. Which was, for what? What was it for? It was for The Changing Room, an English play. Oh, The Changing Room, sorry, sorry, you said that. By David Storrie, which incidentally was first produced at the Royal Court Theater, where we did this play, Giant. So this was full of coming back.
你第一次在百老汇登台。那是为了什么？是为了什么？是为了《更衣室》，一部英国戏剧。哦，《更衣室》，抱歉，抱歉，你刚才说过了。大卫·斯托里的作品，顺便说一句，它最初是在皇家宫廷剧院上演的，也就是我们演《巨人》的那家剧院。所以这充满了回归感。
That's wild, that's cool. Full circle, but you, I mean, imagine coming out and your first production on Broadway, you win it, Tony. You're sort of, you're shot out of a cannon, as it were. You must think like, okay, it's like, it would be like, to try to, for Tracy, it would be like winning the Super Bowl your first year in the NFL.
太疯狂了，太酷了。兜了个圈子，但是你，我是说，想象一下你一出道，在百老汇的第一部作品就赢得了托尼奖。你简直就像是被从大炮里发射出去了一样。你肯定会觉得，好吧，这就好比——对特雷西来说，就像是在NFL的头一年就赢得超级碗一样。
I'm just thinking, I'm gonna win a Super Bowl every year. Right? Was there a little bit of that? Well, it was astonishing. I mean, The Changing Room, it was a play that we did, it was the American premiere of this extraordinary play about an English North of England rugby team.
我当时只是在想，我每年都要赢得一个超级碗。对吧？当时有一点这种感觉吗？嗯，这太令人震惊了。我是说，《更衣室》这出戏，是我们演过的，这是这部关于英格兰北部橄榄球队的非凡戏剧的美国首演。
It takes place in their changing room. It's sort of super realistic. I'll read for that. Yeah, it's a great thing that we did at the Long Wharf Theater in New Haven. And it got a lot of national press and moved to Broadway. Until then, I had done rep for both for my dad and I had actually started directing
它发生在他们的更衣室里。它有点超现实。我来读这段。对，这是我们在纽黑文的长码头剧院做的一件很棒的事。它得到了很多全国性的媒体报道，并搬到了百老汇。在那之前，我一直在为我父亲做剧目团的工作，我甚至开始当导演，
just because nobody would hire me as an actor. I was actually doing well, just fine as a director. I'd been hired to be the artistic director of Baltimore Center Stage and I had accepted. Like, what else, I've gotta work. Wow. And I pulled out after two weeks when I was finally offered to be a member
只是因为没有人愿意雇我当演员。事实上，我当导演做得很好，很顺利。我被聘为巴尔的摩中心舞台的艺术总监，而且我已经接受了。还能怎样，我得工作。哇。但在长码头剧院终于邀请我成为常驻演员公司的成员后，两周后我就退出了。
of the resident company at Long Wharf. The second show was Changing Room and it was brought to Broadway and two weeks later, I won a Tony. How about that? That's crazy. I didn't sleep for about two months. I was so excited.
第二部戏是《更衣室》，它被搬到了百老汇，两周后，我赢得了一座托尼奖。怎么样？太疯狂了。我有大约两个月没睡着觉。我太兴奋了。
Yeah, that's really cool. That's amazing. It really did. It's very hard to get into that inner circle. I mean, in theater in particular in New York, because nobody thinks of you as a successful actor until you're a successful actor. Right.
对，这真的很酷。太神奇了。确实如此。要进入那个核心圈子非常困难。我是说，特别是在纽约的戏剧界，因为在成为一个成功的演员之前，没有人会认为你是一个成功的演员。没错。
Well, speaking about that, having done it so long and at such a high level, do you find yourself still teaching yourself new tricks? Are you, you work with that incredible cast like you just did in Conclave? I imagine it's impossible for you not to absorb something. A little, are you still putting little pieces on
嗯，说到这个，既然你干了这么久，而且达到了这么高的水平，你发现自己还在教自己新的把戏吗？你……你和你在《秘密会议》里合作的那支不可思议的演员阵容一起工作。我想你不可能不吸收一点东西。一点点，你还在给你的，
your talent, does it still change? I feel like there's nothing I haven't done yet. Yeah. I mean, third rock itself was like flying in all directions for six years. It hasn't stopped me from the terrible insecurity of what do people think of me in the first couple of weeks of rehearsal.
你的才华添砖加瓦吗？它还在变吗？我觉得没有什么是我还没做过的。我是说，单单《歪星撞地球》六年里就像是在各个方向飞行。这并没有阻止我在排练的前几周产生那种可怕的不安全感：人们是怎么看我的？
That helped us concentrate though. You know, to be honest, even doing live in front of a studio audience, I was nervous as hell that night. Were you? I don't know whether you guys had that experience. Yeah, well, for Tracy, those were, I know we said it already, but Jimmy Kimmel and Norman Lear put together on ABC
不过这帮我们集中了注意力。老实说，甚至是当着录影棚观众的面进行直播时，那天晚上我都紧张得要命。是吗？我不知道你们有没有过这种经历。对，好吧，对特雷西来说，那是——我知道我们已经说过这个了，吉米·坎摩尔和诺曼·利尔在ABC电视台把这些，
these recreations of old sitcoms and we did them live. Yeah, yeah. It's the one thing all four of us have in common. That's true. I always brag to people that I've worked with Jason and Will. Okay. But I would imagine though that, you know, you work across someone like, you know, Ray Fiennes,
旧情景喜剧重新翻拍，我们进行的是现场直播。对，对。这是我们四个人唯一的共同点。确实如此。我总是向别人吹嘘我和杰森、威尔合作过。好吧。但我会想象，你知道的，你和某个人合作，比如，你知道的，拉尔夫·费因斯，
and like, how can you, how do you avoid not being distracted by watching somebody with that kind of talent, and try to see what they're doing and maybe try it on a little bit for, like, do you find yourself at all being influenced by folks that you're working with? I mean, in the case of Rafe, it was just extraordinary, the interaction.
像这样，你怎么能，你怎么能避免不被看一个拥有这种才华的人所分心，并试图看看他们在做什么，也许自己也去尝试一下？比如，你发现自己会受到你合作的人的影响吗？我是说，就拉尔夫而言，这种互动简直太非凡了。
Yeah. I worked, listen, over the last two years, I've done roles with Rafe Fein's Olivia Colman and Jeffrey Rush. Good Lord. And in big parts, the big intense scenes. You get to see what they do. In each case, they give you so much.
我合作过，听着，在过去的两年里，我和拉尔夫·费因斯、奥利维亚·科尔曼和杰弗里·拉什演过角色。天哪。而且都是大角色，那些节奏紧凑、情感激烈的戏。你有机会看到他们是怎么做的。在每一种情况下，他们都给予了你那么多。
It's all, no performance is created by one person. There's a minimum of two. Because it's all about the interaction and playing off each other. And I just feel, I mean, thank goodness, when I act with someone, they're pretty familiar with me and I tend to be familiar with them. And if I'm not, I make myself friends with them.
这一切，没有哪个表演是由一个人创造的。至少需要两个人。因为这一切都关乎互动和彼此配合。我只是觉得，谢天谢地，当我与某人演戏时，他们对我很熟悉，而我也往往对他们很熟悉。如果我不熟悉，我会让自己和他们交朋友。
I just go right ahead and say, come on, you guys, let's connect. Let's get to know each other. You have to do that. We'll be right back. And back to the show. What's the role that people stop you for the most? And when you're walking down the street,
我直接就会说，得了吧，伙计们，让我们连接起来。让我们互相了解一下。你必须这么做。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。人们因为哪个角色最常拦下你？当你在街上走的时候，
when you're on an airplane and you drop your license, when you, what is the thing that people say to you? I would say probably Third Rock, Dexter and Winston Churchill. But it tends to be the thing that is most current. I mean, an awful lot of things. Well, get ready because the Dumbledore and the Harry Potter series, it's gonna be massive.
当你在飞机上掉落驾照的时候，当你在……人们对你说的最多的是什么？我大概会说是《歪星撞地球》、《嗜血法医》和温斯顿·丘吉尔。但往往是最新的那个角色。我是说，有很多很多。好吧，做好准备，因为《哈利·波特》系列里的邓布利多将会是空前巨大的。
You know, this is already, can you believe this is already started? And the deal was only set like 48 hours ago. And in airports two weeks ago, somehow or other people had gotten wind of this and they were stopping me in airports. Oh yeah. Where are you in your process of educating yourself
你知道的，这已经……你能相信这已经开始了吗？这项协议仅仅是在48小时前才敲定的。两周前在机场，不知怎么的，人们已经风闻此事，他们开始在机场拦住我。哦，是的。你对自己普及整个原作历史的进程进行到哪一步了？
on the history of the whole canon? Well, I seem to be behind everybody. I'm halfway through the second of these seven novels. I think the overall concept of this entire reboot of Harry Potter is an entire season is devoted to a single novel. Oh, that's really cool. Have you guys read those? I read the first one when it came out,
嗯，我好像落后于所有人。我才看完这七部小说的第二部。我想整个《哈利·波特》重启版的总体概念是一整个季度只对应一本小说。哦，那太酷了。你们读过这些书吗？第一本刚出来的时候我读过，
because I wasn't a kid anymore when it came out, and obviously they were huge with children at that time, et cetera, and then, so I was like, well I gotta read it, because I wanna see what everybody's talking about. So I read the first one, and then I didn't go any further, and then once I had kids of my own, I ended up reading all of them out loud to my voice.
因为这书出来时我不再是个孩子了，而且很显然当时它们在小孩子中间非常火，等等，然后我就想，好吧，我得读读，因为我想看看大家都在谈论什么。所以我读了第一本，然后就没再读下去了。接着等我有了自己的孩子，我最后把它们全声朗读给我儿子听了。
Oh, that's amazing. And I've never seen the films. I've only read all the books. You're my audience. Will, you're my audience. Yes. So, wait, really? They're so well made.
哦，那太棒了。我从来没看过电影。我只读过所有的书。你是我的观众，威尔，你是我的观众。是的。等等，真的吗？它们制作得太精良了。
They are, really quick story. So, do you know Darlene Hunt? She's a good friend of mine. She's a writer. She created the Big C show. Yeah, yeah, of course. But anyway, she's a good friend of mine. She's a writer, brilliant. She created the Big C show on. Oh yeah, yeah, of course. But anyway, she's a great writer. And she, her girls were reading the books
确实，说个极短的故事。所以，你认识达琳·亨特吗？她是我的一位好朋友。她是个编剧。她创作了《大C和小C》这部剧。对，对，当然。不过无论如何，她是个好朋友。她是个编剧，才华横溢。她创作了《大C和小C》……哦，对，对，当然。不过无论如何，她是个出色的编剧。然后她，她的女儿们在读书，
when they were really little. And she goes, well, we watched the movie after we read the book, right? And she goes, we're on book four, something like that. I go, why don't you come over and we'll watch the book, we'll watch the thing for you with your family. So she's like, great, I'll pick up a pizza, we'll come over and blah, blah, blah.
当她们还很小的时候。她说，好吧，我们读完书后看了电影，对吧？然后她说，我们看到第四本书了，诸如此类。我说，你们为什么不过来，我们和你们一家一起看这部电影呢？所以她就说，太棒了，我去买个披萨，我们过去吧，巴拉巴拉。
So I go, you know what, we're gonna just go balls out, we're gonna make butter beer for you girls, we're gonna play the music when they walk in. Scotty dressed up as Harry Potter for Halloween once he's gonna put that stupid costume on for your girls. Like it'll be, we'll make them feel like they're coming in, right, the thing. And so she pulls up with a pizza dressed as Maggie Smith
我说，你知道吗，我们要玩把大的，我们要给你们女孩做黄油啤酒，她们一走进来我们就放音乐。斯科蒂有一次万圣节打扮成哈利·波特，他要为你们女孩穿上那套蠢衣服。就像这样，我们会让她们觉得她们走进来了，对吧，就是那种感觉。于是她开车载着披萨到了，打扮成玛吉·史密斯的样子，
in the big pointy hat, you know, Professor McGonagall, with a huge cape and she's all in black and she has a pizza in her hand and she walks in, she's been to my house a million times, she walks in and she sees this dog. She's like, that's weird. And she walks in further, I don't remember that dog. She walks in further and this guy's sitting
戴着尖尖的大帽子，你知道的，麦格教授，披着巨大的斗篷，全身都是黑色的，手里拿着披萨走了进来。她来过我家一百万次了，她走进来，看到了这只狗。她心想：真奇怪。她再往里走，我不记得有这只狗。她再往里走，这有个家伙坐在，
at the kitchen table and goes, can I help you? And she goes, isn't Sean and Scotty live here? And he goes, no, they're next door. So she walked into the wrong house dressed as a witch with a pizza and the guy must have been like, what the fuck is going on? And she may have thought that the dog was a wizard. Yeah.
厨房桌子旁，问道：“我能帮你们吗？”她说：“肖恩和斯科蒂不是住这儿吗？”那人说：“不，他们住在隔壁。”所以她穿着女巫服装拿着披萨走错了房子，那家伙当时肯定在想：这特么是怎么回事？她可能还以为那只狗是个巫师呢。是的。
It was the funniest, most embarrassing story ever. This is another segment of Sean's called Loser Friday Nights. Hey listen, to you. Wait, John, so speaking of this job, this gig that you're going to have for many years, and we talked a little bit about it before, how are you going to do back and forth,
这是史上最搞笑、最尴尬的故事。这是肖恩的另一个环节，叫做“失败的周五之夜”。嘿，听着，对你来说。等等，约翰，说到这份工作，这个你将要做很多年的演出，我们之前稍微讨论过，你打算怎么来回奔波，
and how are your living situations? I mean, do you have to be gone the whole year? You've gone like three months at a time or? I honestly don't know the answer to that, Sean. I mean, I was over in England for eight months for the crown and barely came back. I think I may have come back once or twice. I imagine that I can come back much more.
你的生活状况是怎样的？我是说，你得一整年都不在家吗？你是一次离开三个月左右吗？老实说，我不知道这个问题的答案，肖恩。我是说，为了《王冠》，我在英国待了八个月，几乎都没回来过。我想我可能回来过一两次。我想我可以更经常地回来。
Dumbledore is, he's kind of the nuclear weapon. He only goes off there very, very occasionally. And I think that, I don't think it's gonna be that hard a job and we'll just go back and forth. Where do you like to live? What do you like to live when you're in London? What's your favorite? Well, I've lived in, we lived up near Primrose Hill
邓布利多，他有点像核武器。他只是非常非常偶尔地在那里发射一次。而且我认为，我觉得这不是一份那么难的工作，我们会两边来回跑的。你喜欢住在哪里？你在伦敦时喜欢住在哪里？你最喜欢哪儿？嗯，我住过，我们在《王冠》拍摄期间，
on the Crown. We lived near the Royal Court in Chelsea this past fall when I did the play. And I've had, oh God, they found a wonderful house for us when I did the Crown. And we just lived like Londoners right down the street from Derek Jacoby. That sounds so good, so fun.
住在普里姆罗斯山附近。去年秋天我演这出戏时，我们住在切尔西的皇家宫廷剧院附近。我住过，哦天哪，我拍《王冠》时他们为我们找了一所非常棒的房子。我们就像伦敦人一样住在离杰瑞德·哈里斯很近的街区。听起来太棒了，太有趣了。
I love Derek Jacoby. I love that. So I mean, it's a wonderful thing to contemplate. I mean, the logistics are a little bit scary. I really did have to think hard about whether to take it on. But I also thought, well, I'm about to turn 80, you know, next year. No way. I'll turn 80.
我喜欢杰瑞德·哈里斯。我喜欢那样。所以我的意思是，设想一下这是一件很棒的事。后勤工作确实有点吓人。我确实不得不认真考虑是否要接下它。但我也想，好吧，我明年就要80岁了，你知道的。不可能。我要80岁了。
Wow, is that true? That's the new 50s. Absolutely true. I'm not kidding. You look phenomenal. People ask me for my secret sauce, but I'm beginning to feel like 80. And that means that if this indeed is a seven or eight year long job, it's a wonderful way to grow old as an actor.
哇，真的吗？那是新的50岁。千真万确。我没开玩笑。你看起来状态惊人。人们向我讨教保持年轻的秘诀，但我开始觉得自己就是80岁。这意味着如果这真的是一份长达七八年的工作，对于一个演员来说，这是老去的一种绝妙方式。
I mean, the alternative is to just be hauled out once a year to play an Alzheimer patient. Or to play a wise old wizard. An awful lot of death scenes with weeping middle-aged children. John, and let me just say this. If you played an Alzheimer patient, I'm sure your performance would be unforgettable. By the way, you did in Planet of the Apes.
我的意思是，另一种选择就是一年被拉出来一次，去扮演一个阿尔茨海默病患者。或者去扮演一个充满智慧的老巫师。有相当多的死亡戏，伴随着痛哭流涕的中年儿女。约翰，让我这么说吧。如果你扮演一个阿尔茨海默病患者，我确信你的表演会让人难以忘怀。顺便说一句，你在《猩球崛起》里演过。
You were great. You were an Alzheimer's person. Oh, Sean, I love you. I didn't have to bring that up myself. Yeah, of course. Now, does your wife have to be at UCLA every day teaching? Oh no, no, she has retired from teaching. She still researches and writes and goes to conferences.
你演得太棒了。你演了一个阿尔茨海默病患者。哦，肖恩，我爱你。我都不用自己把这事提出来。对，当然。现在，你妻子必须每天都在UCLA教书吗？哦不，不，她已经从教学生涯中退休了。她仍然在做研究、写作并参加会议。
She travels more than I do. She travels all over the world and I'm a trailing spouse on many occasions. Is Home Bay still Los Angeles though? It's more LA than New York, but we've split our time between the two and now we're triangulating really with London. What a dream, that is my absolute dream. That dream. Mary's from Montana, we have a little cabin on a lake
她旅行得比我还多。她去世界各地旅行，而很多时候我都成了随行配偶。不过洛杉矶依然是你们的大本营吗？比起纽约，这里更像是大本营，但我们在两者之间分配时间，现在实际上和伦敦形成了某种三足鼎立。多么美好的梦想，那绝对是我的梦想。那个梦想。玛丽来自蒙大拿，我们在西北蒙大拿，
in Northwestern Montana and that's kind of our runaway place which is just absolutely beautiful. That's great, that's great. Now if you leave this podcast today without me asking, if you have a funny theater story, these guys will kill me. Oh, yeah. We will love those.
一个湖边有一座小木屋，那是我们的世外桃源，绝对美极了。太棒了，太棒了。如果你今天离开这个播客时，我没有问你有没有一个有趣的剧场故事，这群家伙会宰了我的。哦，是的。我们会很喜欢听这些的。
Out of all of them, because out of all of our guests, because you have such a theater history, and I love when things go wrong, or people forget a line, or somebody having a heart attack, or something in the crowd. Oh or somebody having a heart attack. Or something in the crowd. Oh, Sean loves a heart attack. I did think, I may have said this one to you guys before
在所有这些故事里——因为在我们的所有嘉宾中，你有着如此丰富的戏剧历史，我喜欢事情出错的时候，或者人们忘词的时候，或者有人心脏病发作，或者观众席里发生什么。哦，或者有人心脏病发作。或者观众席里发生什么。哦，肖恩最喜欢心脏病发作了。我确实在想，我可能以前跟你们说过这个，
but I don't remember so stop me if I have. But in high school they were giving these, they created these thespian awards at the end of the year. And they had this award called the Gold Crutch and it goes to who's ever the clumsiest, whoever made the biggest mistakes or whatever. That's a whole other story why I got it. So I go up to accept the Golden Crutch Award
但我不记得了，如果我说过就打断我。但在高中时，他们会在年底颁发这些他们创立的戏剧奖。他们有一个奖项叫“金拐杖”，颁给最笨手笨脚的人、犯最大错误的人或类似的人。至于我为什么拿到它，那是另一个故事了。所以我走上去接受金拐杖奖，
in front of everybody and I thought, you know what might be funny? Is if I trip when I get the award. So I had it in my hand and I tripped and I knocked the tooth out of Missy Vogel Singer's mouth. Oh my God. And she was, I swear to God, Missy Vogel Singer, to this day, and she's standing there shaking and bleeding
在所有人面前，我想，你知道什么会很有趣吗？如果我领奖时摔倒。所以我把它拿在手里，然后我摔倒了，把米西·沃格尔辛格的一颗牙齿给撞掉了。哦天哪。而她当时，我向上帝发誓，米西·沃格尔辛格，直到今天，她当时站在那儿浑身发抖还流着血，
and I'm going, oh God, and the whole audience. It's a bit, it's a bit. And I go, should I do a speech or do I take care of her? And like a true actor, I just gave the speech. Speech, of course the speech. Of course. Did you try to reassure everybody that this was a joke? This was fine.
而我说，哦天哪，全场观众都在看。这真是一场大戏。这真是一出戏。我说，我是该做个演讲还是去照顾她？像个真正的演员一样，我只管做完演讲。演讲，当然是演讲。当然。你有没有试图向大家保证这只是个玩笑？这没问题。
Oh God. The blood was coming down and I was like, oh my God. And it was one of the most embarrassing. By the way, that's why I got the golden crutch. Yeah, well. Any, yeah. I guess the most curious mishap, I mentioned the changing room that I, on Broadway,
哦天哪。血流了下来，我当时想：哦天哪。这是最尴尬的事情之一。顺便说一句，这就是我拿到金拐杖的原因。好吧，对。任何，是的。我想最搞笑的事故，我提到过我在百老汇演的《更衣室》，
which took place in the rugby team's changing room. Twenty-two actors of whom... Cool it, Sean. Fifteen. Fifteen were players, and we, at a certain point, we stripped completely naked, got our uniforms on, we played the match then came back at the end. Halfway through my character,
它发生在橄榄球队的更衣室里。二十二个演员，其中……冷静点，肖恩。十五个。十五个是球员，我们在某个时刻会脱得精光，穿上队服，打完比赛后在最后回来。演到我这个角色的中途，
there was a scene that won me that Tony award. I was brought off the pitch halfway through the match, covered in mud and very, very badly injured. Smashed nose, blood running down my face. I was taken off stage to an off stage bathtub, scrubbed all the mud off and was brought back on stage by the equipment manager. I was stark naked and wet and glistening.
有一场戏让我赢得了那座托尼奖。我在比赛中途被换下场，浑身是泥，而且伤得非常非常重。鼻子碎了，血顺着脸往下流。我被带到后台的一个浴缸里，洗掉了所有的泥，然后由装备经理带回了舞台。我当时一丝不挂，浑身湿漉漉亮晶晶的。
He toweled me down and dressed me up like I was a baby. A long scene in silence. All you heard was the sound of the crowd roaring off stage. And at a certain point, he hoisted me to my feet and hauled my underpants up. These sort of pathetic briefs, you know, we were all these working class clods, really.
他用毛巾把我擦干，像对待婴儿一样给我穿上衣服。有一场长时间的沉默。你只能听到后台人群咆哮的声音。在某个时刻，他把我拉起来，提起我的内裤。这种有点可悲的短内裤，你知道的，我们其实都是些工人阶级的土包子。
But it was a very moving scene. This character was completely out of it. I was like, inert, could barely see. And one night, he hoisted me up, tugged up my briefs, and my dick was sort of hanging out. Just out the bottom, just like, and in front of, you know, 800 people. All sort of stricken in silence.
但那是一场非常感人的戏。这个角色当时已经完全神志不清了。我就像个瘫痪的人，几乎什么也看不清。有一天晚上，他把我拉起来，拽起我的内裤，结果我的丁丁有点垂在外面。就从下面露出来了，差不多就是那样，当着（你知道的）800人的面。
And I thought, how in the world am I going to do this? I'm supposed to be completely inert. And I just sort of thinking nobody would notice, I sort of reached down and sort of flicked it inside my pants. And I would say that was by far the most embarrassing. So yes. That's a good one. After the voting period had already collapsed.
所有人都陷入了震惊的沉默中。我心想：我到底该怎么演下去？我可应该表现得完全瘫痪才对。我心想大概没人会注意到，就伸手下去把这玩意儿拨回了裤子里面。我得说，这绝对是我经历过最尴尬的事。所以，是的。这是一个好故事。在投票期已经结束之后。
I would remind you, I was given a Tony award for that. Yeah, there you go. No wonder. What do we have to do? John, we've taken up too much of your time, but I want to ask you one last question because as Jason mentioned, I imagine over the years, and I know a lot of it is what comes our way, but a lot of stuff I mentioned over there has come your way.
我提醒你们一下，我可是凭那个赢了一座托尼奖的。对，你看。难怪。我们得做点什么？约翰，我们占用了你太多时间，但我还想问你最后一个问题，因为正如杰森所提到的，我想多年来——我知道很多剧本是主动找上门来的，但我刚才提到的很多东西也是找上门来的。
And you mentioned Frasier on Cheers. Is there a role that you have ever regretted other than Frasier Crane, perhaps? Is there a role that you regretted and thought afterwards, I should have said yes? Oh, yes. There are lots. I ordinarily don't tell people out of regard for the ones who ended up playing it. But I would say I must have the record
你提到了《欢乐酒店》里的弗雷泽。除了弗雷泽·克莱恩之外，你有没有哪个角色是曾经后悔过的？有没有哪个角色让你后悔，并事后心想：我当时应该说“好”的？哦，是的。有很多。出于对最终扮演这些角色的演员的尊重，我通常不会告诉别人。但我敢说，我大概保持着一个纪录：
for the most Tony Awards won by actors in roles that I turned down. I think I'm in double figures by now. Oh wow. And a couple of those do indeed completely torment me. Yeah. But I have to think that I played a few roles and had to great acclaim and others have turned it down.
演员因拒绝出演而错失的角色所获得的托尼奖数量，我的记录最多。我到现在大概已经达到两位数了。哦，哇。其中确实有几个真的让我痛心疾首。但我必须认为，我扮演了其他一些角色并获得了巨大赞誉，而其他人也拒绝过这些角色。
John, you know what? And maybe you can look at it like this. You allowed and you gifted but you know Passing on the genius writing and whatever that play was to allow somebody else to to have it and what an incredible You know what an incredible positive thing to will you are so much a much better person than I am You caught him on a good day, John. I eat my heart out, you know. No, but you're absolutely right.
约翰，你知道吗？也许你可以换个角度来看待它。你允许并赋能了……但你知道的，把那些天才剧本或任何那部戏拱手让人，好让别人去拥有它，这是一件多么不可思议的……你知道的，这是一件多么不可思议的积极的事情。威尔，你真是一个比我好得多的人。你今天碰上了约翰状态好的时候，杰森。我心里嫉妒得要命，你知道的。不，但你绝对说得对。
That is a beautiful way to look at it. And as I say, I never tell people that I play. You know, actually, I got a Tony, sorry, an Oscar nomination for Terms of Endearment, replacing another actor. They had shot a couple of scenes with Deborah Winger in Terms of Endearment, and they had to let him go because it just wasn't right. He just didn't feel okay about Deborah Winger having an adulterous affair.
那是一个看待这件事的美丽角度。正如我所说，我从来不告诉别人我演过哪些。你知道的，实际上，我因出演《母女情深》获得过奥斯卡提名，那是顶替了另一个演员。他们当时已经和黛布拉·温格拍了几个场景，但他们不得不让他走，因为那不对劲。他只是觉得黛布拉·温格搞婚外情这件事让他感觉不太对。
So they came after me, thinking I'm the perfect adulterer, apparently. And I have never revealed this actor's name just out of respect for him. Even though there were perfectly good reasons that I just explained why he wasn't right for that part. At that point in your life, you were the seediest person. They were like, we need somebody seedier.
所以他们来找我，显然认为我是完美的通奸者人选。出于对他的尊重，我从未透露过这个演员的名字。尽管正如我刚才解释的那样，有非常充分的理由说明他为什么不适合那个角色。在你生活的那个阶段，你就是最猥琐的人。他们当时就像是：我们需要一个更猥琐的人。
Let's get this out. Seedier, yeah. Exactly. You know, when we did Third Rock, we had something that I called the Lithgow rules. If anybody was ever replaced or dropped from the script, if the part was written out or whatever, that actor would have to get two phone calls,
把这个拿出来。更猥琐，是的。没错。你知道，当我们拍摄《歪星撞地球》时，我们有一个我称之为“利特戈规则”的东西。如果有人被替换或从剧本中除名，如果这个角色被写掉了或者别的什么，那个演员必须接到两个电话，
one from me and one from our producers, just to say, I love that. It wasn't you. We had to hear the reasons why. Because it just has happened so many times in my experience that people are just cut out of films or dropped from. And they don't hear from anybody. They don't hear anything except from a casting director
一个来自我，一个来自我们的制作人，只是为了说：我喜欢那个。不是你的问题。我们必须让他们听到原因。因为在我的经历中，这种情况发生过太多次了：演员无缘无故地被电影剪掉或抛弃。而他们却听不到任何人的消息。他们听不到任何消息，除了选角导演打电话给经纪人，
calling an agent, calling an actor and saying, it didn't work out. And that's so crushing. It's just because there's always 10 perfectly good reasons for things like that. That have nothing to do with the talent. Yeah, and we actors, we can take it. We know there's reasons for it. So there's no reason.
经纪人再打电话给演员说：没合作成。这太打击人了。这只是因为对于这种事情，总是有十个完全合理的理由，而这些理由跟才华毫无关系。是的，我们演员能承受得住。我们知道这是有原因的。所以没有理由。
But we're soft, we're soft. We need to be held. It is that, I've been, well, I've been, you guys probably have too. I mean, I've been fired from jobs before, or my character was written out and I've had, and then there have been people who were really kind of mentioned before, casting director, she's not really doing it anymore, Deb Barelski, and I got fired from a pilot that went to series and I heard nothing.
但我们很脆弱，我们很脆弱。我们需要被拥抱。就是这样，我曾——好吧，我曾经历过，你们可能也一样。我是说，我以前也被工作炒过鱿鱼，或者我的角色被写掉了，我经历过，然后也有一些人——正如刚才提到的选角导演，她现在不怎么干了，黛布·巴雷尔斯基——我曾被一个预定成剧集的试播集解雇，却音讯全无。
And the show got picked up, my character was written off and I was, you know, I wasn't young. I was 32 at the time and I was feeling really shitty in New York and Debrelski wrote me a card, I got it in the mail, in my mailbox here in New York. I got a card saying, they made a mistake, it wasn't you and blah, blah, blah. And it was one of the kinder things.
这部剧被正式预订了，我的角色被写掉了，而我当时——我当时已经不年轻了。我当时32岁，在纽约感觉糟透了。黛布·巴雷尔斯基给我写了一张卡片，我收到了信，就在我在纽约这里的邮箱里。我收到一张卡片上面写着：他们犯了个错误，不是你的问题，巴拉巴拉。那是世上最善良的事情之一。
And a few months later she cast you in Arrested Development and made your career. Actually, and a few months later, she begged me, I was doing a play in New York, and she said, you have to come, and I said, no, I'm not interested, I'm so jaded, and she goes, you have to read for this thing, Arrested Development, oh, fuck.
几个月后，她把你选进了《发展受阻》，成就了你的职业生涯。其实，几个月后，她求我——我当时正在纽约演一出戏，她说：你必须来。我说：不，我不感兴趣，我都对这行感到厌倦了。她说：你必须来为这个叫《发展受阻》的东西试镜。哦，操。
Oh my God, but a great story. And it changed my life. Yeah, that is so nice. And it happens to everyone. I would say this to young actors over and over, it happens to all of us. And it had never happened to me. But I was finally, oh my God,
哦天哪，但真是个好故事。它改变了我的生活。是的，太棒了。而且这种事每个人都会遇到。我会一遍又一遍地对年轻演员说，我们所有人都会遇到这种事。而这种事以前从未发生在我身上。但最后，哦天哪，
I went to the premiere of a film in which I had seven lovely scenes. And I went to the premiere. I was just in New York and I saw, oh, there's a premiere of this film that I'm in. I'll call them and go to the premiere. I was just in New York and I saw, oh, there's a premiere of this film that I'm in. I'll call them and go to the premiere. Well, I sat down and watched my first scene and it was cut in half. And I thought, well, that's too bad. Well, we'll wait for the next one. The next one was cut from the film. The next one was cut. The next one was cut. All that was left of my character was about
我去了一部电影的首映礼，我在里面有七场非常精彩的戏。我去参加了首映礼。我当时正好在纽约，看到：哦，有这么一部我参演的电影的首映礼。我打个电话去参加首映礼好了。我当时正好在纽约，看到：哦，有这么一部我参演的电影的首映礼。我打个电话去参加首映礼好了。好吧，我坐下来观看我的第一场戏，结果它被剪掉了一半。我想，好吧，那太遗憾了。好吧，我们等下一场吧。下一场戏被从电影里删掉了。下一场被删了。下一场被删了。我的角色最后只剩下大约，
the 30 seconds of my first scene in which I had stated the premise of this romantic comedy. But it was enough to trigger residuals. And I sat there with my two kids and just experienced what I'd always told actors, it happens to all of us. Yeah, yeah. It's true. It's such a wild thing, isn't it? It's so wild.
我第一场戏里那30秒，我在里面交代了这部浪漫喜剧的起因。但这足以触发版权尾款了。我坐在那里，带着我的两个孩子，亲身体验了我一直对演员们说的话：这种事我们所有人都会遇到。是的，是的。真的。这真是一件疯狂的事，不是吗？太疯狂了。
John, what an absolute incredible delight having you here today. Well, you guys, it's real. I've always loved this show. I was very honored to be on it. It's so nice of you to join us. You're a real angel. Thank you so much.
约翰，今天你能来到这里，绝对是莫大的荣幸。好吧，伙计们，这是真的。我一直很喜欢这个节目。能来这里我感到非常荣幸。你能加入我们真是太好了。你真是一个天使。非常感谢。
Well, I'm sure I'll see you within the next 48 hours at something. Yeah, you to join us. You're a real angel. Thank you so much. I'm sure I'll see you in the next 48 hours at something. So, yeah. You'll see Jason. You'll see Jason for sure. And we're going to come and see you in London. We're going to come and see Sean and JB. Yeah, absolutely.
好吧，我确信在接下来的48小时内我会在什么地方见到你。是的，你能加入我们。你真是一个天使。非常感谢。我确信接下来48小时内我会在什么地方见到你。所以，是的。你会见到杰森的。你肯定会见到杰森。我们要去伦敦看你。我们要去看肖恩和JB。是的，绝对的。
Sean, I'm going to see Oscar. Good night, Oscar. The great news. That's what I take away from today. Thanks, pal. Thank you. All right, John. Thank you. Oh, and wait, I haven't told you about my history with Bennett.
肖恩，我要去看奥斯卡。晚安，奥斯卡。好消息。这就是我从今天带走的东西。谢谢你，老兄。谢谢你。好了，约翰。谢谢。哦，等等，我还没跟你讲我和贝内特的历史呢。
I was gonna do a deep dive on Bennett Barbecue. Yeah, look at that! Here's the portrait by John Lithgow. What? There's the portrait. You did that? That's my painting of Bennett, yeah. Isn't that pretty good?
我本来想深入聊聊贝内特·巴比卡。对，看看这个！这是约翰·利特戈画的肖像。什么？有这幅肖像。这是你画的？那是我的贝内特画像，对。画得挺不错的吧？
Wow, that's fantastic. You look more like the painting than ever. It's like the portrait of Dorian Gray. I was John's muse. How are you guys connected? Wait a second, so Bennett Barbica, who works with us on the show, who's here now, how do you and Bennett know each other?
哇，太棒了。你看起来比以往任何时候都更像这幅画了。这就像《多林·格雷的画像》一样。我曾是约翰的缪斯。你们是怎么认识的？等一下，所以和我们在节目中合作、现在也在这里的贝内特·巴比卡，你和贝内特是怎么认识的？
Bennett was like one of my daughter's very good friends at Seeds UES School when they were about seven, eight, nine years old. And I know Bennett's folks all these years. We exchanged Christmas cards. Wait, wait, Bennett, you went to the lab school? I sure did before it was called lab school, yeah. And yeah, and both my kids, my older kids,
贝内特是我女儿在种子UES学校上学时，大约七八九岁时的好朋友之一。这些年来我都认识贝内特的父母。我们互寄圣诞贺卡。等等，等等，贝内特，你上过实验室学校？我当然上过，在它叫实验室学校之前，是的。是的，而且我的两个孩子，我较大的孩子们，
both my older kids went to lab school, John. Amazing, circles within circles. But his parents, I put up for a fundraising dinner. I offered to paint a portrait of your child. And they bid and they won, and so I painted Bennett's portrait. Although I have to say. That's crazy.
我较大的两个孩子都上了实验室学校，约翰。太神奇了，圈子里面套着圈子。但他的父母，我为一场募捐晚宴出了力。我主动提出为他们的小孩画一幅肖像。他们出价并赢了，所以我画了贝内特的肖像。虽然我不得不说，
It took me about seven years to paint it. It was a source of great guilt. But I finally showed up. That's amazing. How cool is that, Bennett? When people come over, you go, look at that. John Lithgow did that. It says J. But I finally showed up. That's amazing. How cool is that, Bennett? When people come over, you go, look at that. John Lithgow did that for me. This says JL at the bottom.
这太疯狂了。我花了大约七年时间才画完。这曾是我极大的负罪感来源。但我最后还是现身了。太神奇了。这太酷了，贝内特？当人们过来时，你会说：看那个。那是约翰·利特戈画的。上面写着“J”。但我最后还是现身了。太神奇了。这太酷了，贝内特？当人们过来时，你会说：看那个。那是约翰·利特戈为我画的。这底部写着“JL”。
That's cool. Bennett, Bennett, your mom and dad love you. You see, I told you I always wanted to be an artist, and it turns out it's not too late. Pretty good. It's never too late. That's amazing. That's amazing.
太酷了。贝内特，贝内特，你的爸爸妈妈很爱你。你看，我告诉过你我一直想成为一名艺术家，结果证明现在还不算太晚。挺不错的。永远都不会太晚。太神奇了。太神奇了。
Thank you for that, John. That's amazing. Oh, well, thank you, Bennett. I'm glad we squeezed that in. Yes, absolutely. So thank you for that, John. That's amazing. Oh, well, thank you, Bennett. I'm glad we squeezed that in. Yes, absolutely. So good to see you, John. Okay, you too. Bye-bye now.
谢谢你，约翰。太神奇了。哦，好吧，谢谢你，贝内特。我很高兴我们把这个塞进去了。是的，绝对的。很高兴见到你，约翰。好的，你也是。再见啦。
Bye, guys. Bye-bye. Bye, John. Now, we have had some assholes. We have had, you know, but this son of a bitch. Jason, Jason, hold up, man. No, wait. Jason, Jason.
再见，伙计们。拜拜。再见，约翰。现在，我们遇到过一些混蛋。我们遇到过，你知道的，但这个狗娘养的……杰森，杰森，等等，伙计。不，等等。杰森，杰森。
What a delight, my God. Jesus, I know. I feel like I've known him. I feel like he's a good, good, good guy. Wow, I can't believe he's almost 80. He looks younger than Jason, it's fucking crazy. I gotta see him play that killer because I can't imagine him ever being nasty. Ever being angry, you can.
真是太开心了，天哪。天哪，我知道。我感觉我认识他很久了。我觉得他是个很好、很好、很好的人。哇，我不敢相信他快80岁了。他看起来比杰森还年轻，这他妈太疯狂了。我得看看他演那个杀手，因为我无法想象他会有哪怕一点点讨厌的样子。永远那么生气，你能想象吗。
You see through it, you think it's all bullshit. No, no, no, I don't mean it that way. I mean that he is such a versatile, he has such facility as an actor. I mean, he has played, I'm trying to think, he's played like some sort of- Raising Cain. Yeah, Raising Cain.
你能看透它，你觉得这全都是扯淡。不，不，不，我不是那个意思。我的意思是他是如此多面，他作为演员有如此惊人的才华。我的意思是，他演过——我尽量想一想，他演过某种——《夺命佳人》。对，《夺命佳人》。
Yeah, some scary, scary characters. And he's played like some sort of... Raising Cain. Yeah, Raising Cain. Yeah, Raising Cain did some scary characters. And he's still doing theater. I mean, how about he's like, yeah, I'm doing Dumbledore. Oh, I'm going to do this play though, before that. I'm like, God, doesn't slow down. It's very inspiring. But anyway, it's great, great call getting him. I love him, I love him.
对，一些吓死人的角色。而且他还演过某种——《夺命佳人》。对，《夺命佳人》。对，《夺命佳人》里有一些吓人的角色。而且他还在演话剧。我是说，他怎么能像这样：“哦，我要演邓布利多。哦，不过在那之前我要演这出戏。”我当时想：天哪，他一点都没慢下来。这太激励人了。不过无论如何，能把他请来真是太棒太棒的决定了。我爱死他了，我爱死他了。
We were supposed to have him on before and there was a thing and it was messed up and it was so, we had a technical error, one of our episodes that didn't work out and I was like, oh my God, are we ever gonna get him back because he's traveling all the time and he's working all the time and I just thought, God, I'm so happy
我们本来应该早点请他来的，中间出了点岔子，搞砸了，结果我们遇到了技术故障，我们有一期节目没弄好，当时我想：天哪，我们还能把他请回来吗，因为他一直在旅行，一直在工作，我当时就想，天哪，我太高兴了，
that we were actually able to make it happen. Yeah, he's great. Yeah, I mean, he's just, I'll bet you could rattle off at least a dozen movies that you go, that's right, he was in that. He's just always got some great part in some great project that you forget about. Oh dude, he's been in everything.
我们居然真的能把它办成。对，他太棒了。是的，我是说，他简直——我敢打赌你能随口说出至少十多部电影，你会说：没错，他演了那个。他总能在某些伟大的项目中扮演一些你都快忘掉的极佳角色。哦，老兄，他什么都演过。
Right, right. Yeah, I mean, if you take them all. Boy. All his films. Yeah, it's the pause, it's the pause. That's what it is, Jason, it's take them all... Boy. All his films and all his work. It's the pause. It's the pause. That's what it is, Jason. It's the pause that he takes. You can also hear the engine start. Yeah, that's true.
对，对。是的，我的意思是，如果你把它们都拿走。天哪。他所有的电影。是的，就是停顿，就是停顿。就是这样，杰森，就是把它们都拿走……天哪。他所有的电影和所有的作品。就是停顿。就是停顿。就是这样，杰森。就是他那短暂的停顿。你还能听到发动机启动的声音。是的，确实如此。
If you take all of them and put them together, and it would be such... It's such an incredible body of work if you take them all and you come... Fine! ...fine! Yo! That's terrible. That was terrible. Smart. Come... Bye! Good? Good? No! That's terrible.
如果你把它们全部拿出来放在一起，那将是……如果你把它们全部拿出来，然后来……好吧！……好吧！哟！太糟糕了。太糟糕了。聪明。来……再见！好吗？好吗？不！太糟糕了。
That was terrible. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
太糟糕了。聪明。少一点。聪明。少一点。聪明。少一点。聪明。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
少一点。聪明。少一点。聪明。少一点。聪明。少一点。聪明。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry and Rob Armgerf. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
少一点。聪明。少一点。聪明。少一点。聪明。少一点。SmartLess由Bennett Barbico、Michael Grant Terry和Rob Armgerf100%有机手工制作。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。